some very interesting discussions I
spotted this morning on the David Pakman
show subreddit this is a place where
nearly 6,000 of our viewers and
listeners regularly talk to each other
about politics about what's going on
with the show
etc david pakman.com slash subreddit is
where you can access that one post that
i noticed this morning is a post that i
noticed this morning says does anyone
else think the way so what did I say did
I not say right at david pakman.com
slash subreddit oh I'm sorry
yeah pat was looking at me like I had
three heads and I was like that I must
be david pakman.com slash read it thank
you I've never seen Pat look so shocked
but yes david pakman.com slash record
does anyone else think the way so many
liberals use terms and phrases that
right-wingers love is really stupid so
the question here is when we jokingly on
the Left use terms like Chuck and
snowflake and triggered and all that
stuff are we doing something positive by
sort of ridiculing the terms that the
right is using or are we doing something
negative by sort of in a way suggesting
that the terms are valid terms or
allowing the political discourse to be
lowered or diminished I tend to be in
the latter camp and it's it's funny
because I sometimes will use jokingly or
satirically the term triggered or
special snowflake or cocked or whatever
and I am making fun of the right using
those terms but in in the big picture
I'm gonna try to make an effort not to
do that because I do think that once you
start using these terms then it's just
semantics about who the cuck is and
you're legitimizing the concept of
pointing out kuck
as political discourse so I actually
agree with some of the commenters here I
like using it on occasion one because
it's funny yeah but two it's important I
think to point out to right-wingers that
they can be overly sensitive on issues
be at the national anthem protest yeah
where the war on Christmas or the
serenity of the flag I don't disagree
with that but I that in the same way but
I am going to try to make an effort not
to use the terms in order to not
diminish political discourse to their
level also from our subreddit here's how
to share as little data as possible
without deleting Facebook yeah this is
an interesting article now in the wake
of the Facebook data scandal of a Good
Samaritan posting to the David Pakman
show subreddit if you don't want to get
rid of Facebook altogether because you
like some of the elements of keeping in
touch with the people you're in touch
with on it
how can you lock it down to share as
little data as possible and a very very
good guide to that so far I'm keeping
Facebook I really do use it for a lot of
show related stuff day to day but I am
concerned about what's going on for sure
next discussion is about how one of our
users they're suggesting that white
house officials are stuck between a rock
and a hard place if they leak
information regarding their advice to
the president they break protocol and
Trump might fire them if they don't leak
the information they risk the president
claiming that idiotic things he says or
does were on the advice of his staff I
do not envy for a second any staffer of
trumps right now I think that it's
ultimately their choice to work for him
so I'm not saying that they are not
responsible for their decision to work
for Trump but I don't envy them it seems
like it's really really bad at the Oval
Office and this is just one way and
lastly from the David Pakman show
subreddit David should talk about the
storm the next big thing in bright wing
conspiracy world apparently I haven't
heard of this apparently there is this
thing called the storm that the
alt-right or right-wingers are talking
about it's some kind of conspiracy but
I've not heard about it yet so I'm gonna
make an effort to inform myself about it
over the next 24 to 48 hours participate
join in the discussion on the david
pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com /re d di t